The Council recently held its March meeting,
and here’s a brief recap of some of the
items discussed.
Judge John Brandts-Giesen was presented with
a Community Service Award.
It recognises the time and dedication he has
provided to various charities and organisations
within the Waimakariri District and across
New Zealand.
He was a solicitor in Rangiora for 22 years,
and was appointed as a Judge in 2016.
The Council confirmed the name of the new
cycleway and walkway currently being built
between Rangiora and Woodend.
It will be known as the Rangiora-Woodend Path.
It’s expected to be completed in middle
of the year, following the recent successful
opening of the Passchendaele Memorial Path
between Kaiapoi & Rangiora.
And following consultation with the community,
new speed limits were approved for Lees Road
and Barkers Road in Kaiapoi.
Both roads will now have a speed limit of
50km/h reduced from the current 80km/h.
Feedback from local residents was strongly
in favour of a reduction.
The next monthly Council meeting will take
place on Tuesday 3rd April
at Council Chambers in Rangiora.